woman as a partner or as a property
best as in
as a wife
No,
but partner.
No partner or partner
is such a technocratic word.
partners are in the company
but she knocked over love
partner in the sense of
that there is a person
who loves
but not livestock
ym hesitated
I don't know if you sent a coup.
This is not Patrick's foundation.
I know what your questions are about.
no pandemic foundation
archate and taboo and janusz in common with this event
but why was there Januszka then
Dominika maybe they invited him
And that's where the gentlemen were debating.
not that
In the past,
a woman was treated like a boy.
With luggage you know